blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman welcome to the show we have to
start today with what could be a real
disaster for democrats in california in
the california gubernatorial recall
election we've talked about it a little
bit on the bonus show
and i mean to bottom line it for you
we could be looking at democrats not
only losing control of the um uh
governorship in california
but losing control because of a pathetic
or apathetic
turnout from democrats and losing
control to an absolutely
radical
destructive embarrassing republican
named larry elder and we're going to
talk about that as well the way that the
recall election works is it's relatively
easy to recall a governor in california
arnold schwarzenegger came to power and
ultimately became governor in california
because of the low bar for a recall of
then governor gray davis and similarly
the current recall effort
is overwhelmingly being carried out by
republicans
in california democrats have a huge
voter registration advantage and so when
you look at polling you find
that the um
it's it's basically
50 50ish when it comes to whether in in
the polling whether you between
democrats and republicans whether you
want to recall gavin newsom democrats
have a far larger share of the voters
but the question is will they turn up
and it's sort of a two-part election the
first part is do you want to recall the
governor
if that is a yes then who is it that you
would like to see become governor and
larry elder is is leading in uh just
about every poll there i know someone
called in last week and said this guy
kevin paffrath who i know a little bit
i've been on his show he's a youtuber
kevin paffrath is polling first in most
polls i've seen kevin paffrath is not
polling first he's polling a pretty
distant second
and uh what is really important to
understand is that only 36 percent of
all registered voters want to remove
gavin newsom
but when you look at likely voters it
goes up to 47
and this is that problem i'm talking
about when it comes to the heavily
democratic state of california most
people want to keep gavin newsom when
you look at only those who are likely to
vote it's very close to 50 50. and as
there's a good article in the guardian
about this
apathetic voters could hand california
recall to republicans folks seem unaware
gavin newsom remains popular but
democrats of fear appear far less likely
than republicans to vote in the election
with california's gubernatorial recall
election underway newsom is fighting for
his political life the democratic
governor of a deep blue state could
narrowly lose his seat to a fringe
right-wing radio host in large part due
to inertia and apathy among voters
democrats outnumber republicans nearly
two to one in california but while the
former are distracted and disengaged the
latter are riled up political
strategists and pollsters say by voting
at higher rates republicans could
capture the governor's seat for the
first time in a decade and then again
those numbers i mentioned
only 36 percent of all registered voters
want to oust newsom but that number
rises to 47 percent when polling likely
voters that's a uc berkeley poll a
recent cbs news poll found that 72
percent of republican voters are very
motivated but only 61 percent of
democrats feel the same um it is really
important to understand that the
motivation that republicans have
comes from hate
it comes from lies that they've been
told and that they believe and you only
have to look at video from a larry elder
event to figure out what is going on we
played video of this last week larry
elder did an event he's the republican
leading candidate for those who want to
recall he's a republican very radical
guy
he did an event where he said if i am
elected governor i will repeal or ban
any mask or vaccine mandates that are in
place at the time and the guy got a
standing ovation from the crowd that's
the type of thing that is motivating the
people that want to remove gavin newsom
um many are asking as well
isn't this the exact same scenario as
with arnold schwarzenegger because there
was a recall done of a democratic
governor
democrats maybe assumed we're going to
win this easily because it's california
and then arnold schwarzenegger ended up
winning it this is a very different
scenario so although it could be really
bad for democrats it's a different
situation than back in the early 2000s
schwarzenegger won with 48 of the vote
and democrats had put up like a real
candidate lieutenant governor bustamante
who got 33 percent
um if the 2021 democrats
put up and had an actual candidate
running in the recall side it would
potentially be a very different scenario
now kevin paffrath i believe is running
as a democrat but really is is a
republican and is running as a democrat
for strategic reasons not a real
democrat in that sense and so what you
have is the incumbent democratic
governor
simply running on say no to the recall
vote not to remove me
but if that doesn't happen it will
almost certainly be radical republican
larry elder who win so it's just a
completely different scenario now a
little bit about larry elder
larry elder to give you a sense of what
could end up taking place if larry elder
wins
larry elder was a big supporter of
donald trump that should instantly
disqualify you of course
uh believes that donald trump has
nothing uh uh bears no responsibility
for the january sixth trump riots
in one of his books larry elder called
for getting rid of the irs altogether
putting in place a national sales tax
reducing government by 80
ending welfare ending entitlements
getting rid of the minimum wage and
getting rid of corporate taxes that's
his package of economic ideas that he
wrote about some some time ago
uh larry elder has argued that roe v
wade should be overturned which would
essentially uh allow abortion to just be
made flat out against the law
has referred to abortion as murder has a
long history of tweeting anti-lgbt
things published and gave air time to
serious misinformation and very fringe
views
on all sorts of different science topics
this includes the
negative health effects of smoking
cigarettes
climate change and of course treatments
unproven treatments for covid19 and i
could go on and on and on and so the
message here is
it may be that because of democratic
apathy in california
we will have a major loss for the left
which would be having a state like
california with such a democratic
advantage in terms of party registration
we could see the democratic party lose a
governorship and not only lose it but
lose it to a wacky right winger like
larry elder because republicans are far
more motivated than democrats in
california i've spoken anecdotally
so okay i've spoken to some democrats in
california who understand what's going
on and plan to vote and are telling
people we've got to get active or we're
going to end up we're going to sleep
through
a radical republican takeover of the
state of california there are others who
have no idea this is even going on and
that's really the concern and the low
threshold for doing a recall in
california
systemically creates this situation
where you can have a relatively small
group of very motivated and very radical
republicans
um overwhelm the will of the state
overall which is it's a very
left-leaning state because a lot of
those left-leaning people choose not to
vote so that's a very very bad thing
we've got to make sure everybody
understands what's going on and we'll
have more coverage of the california
recall
probably uh next week and and into the
recall election in mid-september let's
talk a little bit about florida we have
i mean i guess i would sort of call this
good news out of florida in the sense
that in politics you often get reverse
consequences so like think back to the
2016 republican primary which really
started in 2015. donald trump arrived
with no experience
no
reasonable ideas
no credible path to getting anything
done
and
he was rewarded
by
becoming the republican nominee and
ultimately president of the united
states and similarly we have seen in the
state of florida
radical covid governor ron desantis
experience the covet hellscape that
florida has become
and not really suffer when it comes to
polling and when it comes to approval
that seems now to have changed and that
is very good news ron desantis's poll
numbers have started to plummet
as the coveted numbers in florida
continue to get worse and worse and
worse and what impact this will have on
his gubernatorial reelection campaign
and possibly his eventual candidacy for
the republican uh presidential
nomination we just don't know but let's
look at this report from truthout
florida governor ron desantis is seeing
approval ratings plunge after enacting
and seeking to enforce stringent
measures to prevent schools in florida
from taking actions to prevent the
spread of coronavirus earlier this year
desantis signed a bill into law that
banned local governments including
school districts from issuing rules
about masking despite a cdc
recommendation that every school require
masking to prevent students and staff
from contracting and spreading covid19
after several school districts said they
would keep their masking rules in place
desantis threatened to withhold the pay
of district officials and punishment for
their defiance even though they were
acting in the interest of public health
desantis went forward with the threats
despite polling in a state showing that
most people support policies made at the
local level to keep masking in place in
fact most americans back masking
requirements in schools and florida's no
different around 62 percent of florida
voters support rules requiring masks for
students and staff
now new polling shows desantis may have
harmed himself politically over his
stubborn stance on masking a political
matrix listener group survey asks
florida residents where they whether
they have a positive or negative view of
the governor on his handling over of the
pandemic only 43 percent say favorable
53 almost 54 percent say unfavorable
importantly this puts desantis at a
disadvantage against his potential
political opponents he's up for
re-election in 22. in a hypothetical
matchup against uh u.s congressman
charlie crist the santis would lose the
governorship 43-57 and desantis is also
polling uh
fairing poorly against the florida
agriculture commissioner nikki freed
freed would win about 54 to 46. we have
this new polling data it is very
interesting to look at this is the poll
that's referred to
and we'll go through some of the numbers
first when rating the handling of the
pandemic desantis has 54 either
unfavorable or very unfavorable when you
break it out by party lines republicans
are still strongly supportive 62 66.2
percent have a combined favorable and
very favorable
the poll goes on to find next we see a
complete flip from eight weeks ago with
today charlie crist leading desantis
57-43
what seems to be the biggest part
is the amount of grasp each has within
their party
with democrats christ has almost 90
percent of his base with republicans
desantis is down to only 75 percent of
republican responders so that's an
important signal and that's similar
actually to what we saw uh with donald
trump where you saw
uh joe biden
going into the 2020 election carrying
almost every democrat whereas donald
trump was still carrying a majority but
a smaller majority of republicans and of
course we know how that ultimately
turned out so you know this really
shouldn't be news like this is what we
call logical when people's opinion
reflects and responds to what takes
place in the real world
that's logical and that makes sense
we've become so used to seeing
republicans reward the worst people and
the worst political performance that in
a way we're sort of like surprised wow
desantis has ruined florida over kovid
and his approval rating is plummeting it
makes sense but it still surprises us
now someone wrote to me and said you
know what's going on david ron desantis
supporters are dying of covet so he's
losing approval
that's
the math doesn't check out on that for
now but it could
over time you could actually start to
see
the fact that it's disproportionately
republicans who were dying of the virus
because it's disproportionately the
unvaccinated who are dying of the virus
it could start to make a difference and
what i mean by that is as of about 10
days ago
1500 vaccinated people have died of
covered nationally and meanwhile a
thousand people a day are dying so total
1500 vaccinated but every day a thousand
are dying overwhelmingly the
unvaccinated over time
you could see a state like florida where
ron desantis only won by 33 000 but it
now has 42 000 coveted deaths it's
conceivable you could get to a point
where the death partisan gap
could cost ron desantis
a lot more people would have to die
because remember not everybody votes so
of the 42 000 that died
probably about half or actual voters
maybe even less and then within that you
have to look at the partisan split it
might only be a seven or eight thousand
dollar uh sorry seven or eight thousand
death gap between parties so
very rough estimate unless you see a
hundred and twenty thousand a hundred
and forty thousand dead in florida
uh with a big partisan gap i don't know
that it would actually lead to desantis
losing because his voters died but the
fact that we're even talking about how
far are we from that math making sense
tells you how insane the situation has
become in florida if you're in florida
let me know what the mood is there let
me know what 2022 is looking like that's
a big if democrats were able
to hold california in the recall
and take florida in 2022 it would be a
really big deal
heading into 2024. let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
dpakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that if you like this show or
at least sort of you can get more of it
every day we do an extra show called the
bonus show for our website members every
single day you can sign up at
coupon code available not mandatory
better21 save yourself about 40 percent
um and also you can get the commercial
free audio and video stream of the show
every day as a website member want to go
through some interesting posts i spotted
this morning on the david pakman show
subreddit you can join more than 32 000
of our viewers and listeners
on the subreddit at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t
couple of different uh things one is i
don't know how many of you saw this
video of rudy giuliani
shaving his face with a an electric
razor battery powered i guess
technically at an airport
uh restaurant i did see the video i
didn't really have much to say about it
but it's gotten a bunch of attention on
the subreddit there's something very sad
about it and we've talked a lot uh now
about rudy giuliani's sort of fall from
grace
and it it's not
you know i've said i don't really feel
bad in the sense that he really brought
this on himself a guy who was widely
praised and beloved even by some
democrats rightly or wrong wrongly after
9 11 he was mayor of new york city at
that point in time uh and just
squandered all the goodwill ended up not
only becoming a big vocal supporter of
donald trump's but also going out of his
way like you can casually support trump
but you don't have to go around
spreading election lies and passing
covid
but he did that
and ultimately was suspended by the bar
in washington dc i believe in new york
due to reciprocity and ended up
being becoming the target of
investigations which we don't know
ultimately where where that will end
having his home raided having his
workplace raided um
you know farting multiple times in
public during public hearings and just
humiliating himself in all ways it's
really stuff he's brought on himself but
as as funny as the video is of rudy
shaving
sitting there at a table at an airport
restaurant shaving
it did also kind of bum me out you know
he's close to 80 years old and it just
seems like it's all kind of falling
apart for for him i'm not saying that it
he didn't bring it on himself i'm just
saying the video did bum me out a little
bit curious to hear your thoughts um
another user on the david pakman show
subreddit posted a trump has told me it
doesn't take a genius to believe the
election was stolen i simply said you
are 100 right and i'm sure that this
went over your trumpist friends or
acquaintance's head
but um you know what what i do i mean
i've been getting more and more calls
when we take live calls on the show
um and even i've been getting texts from
friends about you know i have this
anti-vaxxed person at work and i've been
getting into arguments or whatever
my um
advice
take it for what it take take it for
what you're paying for it which is
nothing right right uh my advice is
increasingly to people i know personally
and to people who call in
i don't know that i would engage
one-on-one with these folks i think it's
better to engage with campaigns and
public awareness initiatives and
whatever else
in order to get people understanding
facts and understanding whether it's
anti-vaxx or whatever things about the
election i don't really know that
there's much to gain from these
one-on-one arguments and the amount of
stress and anxiety that i see it causing
people in my audience and people people
around me i just don't know that it's
worth it and so this approach just
saying you know what you're right it
doesn't take a genius to end up
believing that donald trump actually won
the election i would go more in that
direction because at some point you've
got to do what's best for yourself and
it seems it's really bad for a lot of
people to be engaging in fruitless
conversations with ignorant people
who have been the targets of weaponized
disinformation and propaganda that's my
sense but if you think it just makes
sense to keep arguing let me know i'm
open to that that idea
lastly
we're starting to think about and talk
about the 2022 midterms
and user highway agitated
posted what would count as a good
midterm to you
we will probably lose the house but a
seven seat loss would have republicans
at 219 216 not hard to crawl out of in
2024 a good midterm could also mean
picking up arizona georgia and new
hampshire governorships also senate
pickups in pennsylvania wisconsin north
carolina we could also flip state
legislatures in arizona michigan
pennsylvania north carolina i actually
think it's just too early to say what a
good midterm would look like obviously a
good midterm would be one where
republicans don't take control of the
house or senate
i know that there are lots of people
already kind of calling it a lost cause
and saying obviously democrats are going
to lose x y and z i just think it's too
early you know
a few months ago we were saying
if kovid continues improving and biden
is attached to that it could be a really
good midterm rachel bittikoffer came on
the show and said it could be okay it
also could be a disaster in the
aftermath of afghanistan it started
seeming like wow democrats are tainted
and it's just going to not go well but
at the same time voters tend to have
short political memories i just think
it's too early at this point i was going
over this is actually interesting
i had a call with our youtube rep last
week
and we were just going over for planning
purposes when when does the mid-term
typically start in terms of media
interest
it's typically way later uh it's often
not until april although more recently
it's been more like march and and this
year is expected to maybe get going as
early as february the point is i think
we probably have at least five or six
months i think we've got to see what how
does kovid go through the fall and
winter
does joe biden get another major
accomplishment is anybody still talking
about afghanistan in january february i
think in mid-february we will start to
get a sense of what the midterms are
going to look like and at that point
i'll tell you what is a sort of good
better best and disaster scenario join
the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit i want to do a little bit of an
update on a story there is a news story
here but it there also isn't in the
sense that we already had the facts
about the real
covid mortality and fatality rate in the
state of new york there are a bunch of
different headlines now which say things
like
new york governor acknowledges nearly 12
000 more coveted fatality fatalities
than publicized by andrew cuomo
and the story goes new york governor
kathy hoechel promised more government
transparency on her first day in office
and by day's end her administration had
quietly delivered it by acknowledging
nearly 12 000 more deaths in the state
from covid19 than had been publicized by
her predecessor andrew cuomo new york
now reports nearly 55 400
um based on death certificate
see up from 43
400 that cuomo had reported to the
public as of monday his last name in
office we are now releasing more data
than had been released before publicly
so people know the nursing home deaths
and hospital deaths are consistent with
what's being displayed by the cdc got a
bunch of emails from people saying david
i don't understand
i looked on you know world domiters and
the cdc website nothing changed and
that's exactly right the scandal here
was
that the uh cuomo administration was not
acknowledging roughly these 10 to 12
what was 10 now is known to be 12 000
coveted deaths
but the cdc was always acknowledging
them and websites like worldometers and
others are based on cdc data so
this is more of a political story than
it is a whoa there's actually 12 000
more people that died we knew about that
and we reported it um feels like it's
been a couple of months since we we
learned of that now when it comes to
andrew cuomo
what is even worse the covet stuff or
the sexual harassment stuff i think at
the macro level not to diminish what
andrew cuomo has been credibly accused
of based on a report i think that the
covet stuff without a doubt has been
worse
but this is not actually new information
it's just that it's now being
acknowledged formally by the state uh
good to see the new governor acknowledge
it at the same time
uh there's an aspect of this that seems
very political in the sense that the
data was already out there we covered it
months ago this sort of is like a get
out of jail free card for everybody else
in the executive branch and it's
probably legitimate to say really this
is andrew cuomo
they threw cuomo out cuomo gets the
blame and now kathy hoechel or is it
hokel actually don't know how it's
pronounced um acknowledges it and it's
sort of like hey everything's good now
while the truth is it's very hard to
imagine that more people within
the
administration of the state government
of new york didn't know that this was
going on so there's an aspect of this
that feels like this is the perfect
timing to just acknowledge it and move
on and try to avoid any other
consequences for anybody now that
cuomo's gone and the numbers match the
cdc
but in some sense it's good that they
have now said yes this is the real
number of deaths here in the state of
new york if you think that this has any
importance beyond just quietly putting
it out there so that now they can move
on and try to prevent anybody else
from having any kind of consequence as a
result
let me know but the data's not new and
it seems to me like a pretty brazen act
of
say it sweep it under the rug and then
if it ever comes up again say that was
on cuomo and cuomo is now gone we've
taken care of the problem everybody's
gotten the consequence they deserve
let me know we'll be covering this more
on our instagram where you can find us
at david pakman show find me on
instagram as well at david david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
okay let's follow up on a couple of
different stories that we've been
covering for some time you might
remember that sort of in the in the
middle of
the 2020 era of the pandemic there was
this plot to kidnap the democratic
michigan governor gretchen whitmer and a
number of people were arrested for that
we have now learned what the
consequences will be
for one of the uh co-conspirators i
guess we would call them there a
michigan man who admitted to taking part
in an extremist group's plot to kidnap
gretchen whitmer in retaliation for
covid restrictions was sentenced
yesterday to over six years in prison
the man is 25 year old ty garban is the
only person to have pleaded guilty out
of the more than a dozen men facing
state and federal charges stemming from
the plot so understand that this guy got
more than six years
he pleaded guilty and cooperated the
others are presumably going to trial
and this guy still got six years so just
think about what might be coming for
some of the other individuals here
five of those charged in federal court
pleaded not guilty and faced trial in
october
u.s district judge robert jonker
sentenced garban to 75 months in prison
three years of probation and a 2500 fine
during the sentencing hearing garben
apologized to whitmer who was not
present this guy essentially threw
himself at the mercy of the court
pleaded guilty cooperated and apologized
and still got more than six years
at least in theory of course it'll
depend on exactly what charges all
others are convicted of if at all
you could be looking at way longer
prison sentences for the others um the
individual ty garvin said quote first i
would like to take this opportunity to
apologize to governor greta gretchen
whitmer and her family i've had a lot of
time to reflect on my actions and i
never realized what my actions would
have caused to her but also her family i
can't even imagine the amount of stress
and fear her family fem members felt
because of my actions and for that i am
truly sorry
garbin also apologized to his friends
and family i never took into
consideration the emotional effect that
my actions would take on them and for
that i was truly selfish to not take
into consideration my family members
that have meant so much to me he
expressed the desire to continue to
de-radicalize himself
and help prevent others from becoming
radicalized and going down the same path
so
that's great if that stuff is true it
very well might be completely
disingenuous and what his lawyer said
say this in order to get the lightest
possible sentence it doesn't really
matter he was willing to do it and what
i am so so two thoughts here basically
first of all
they have to throw the book at these
guys it has to be made very clear
that it is not uh it is not a
serious modern society
if you can plot to kidnap
one of the
uh the the top state official the
governor
um and get away with the slap on the
wrist it can't happen and so this is a
guy who
expressed remorse genuine or
disingenuous i don't know but he
expressed remorse he cooperated
he
is getting all the right buzzwords i
want to indeed
de-radicalize myself and i apologize to
everybody
and pleaded guilty and more than six
years in prison he will now have to do
um the other 11 individuals and again
only some of those we we know sort of
the path
uh to trial that is taking place but the
other up to 11 individuals could they
end up with more than a decade in prison
uh we don't know we'll have to wait but
this is exactly the way that this needs
to be handled because this is
extraordinarily serious and
unfortunately you know the there's this
very similar dynamic with the january
six trump rioters and we've started to
see some of those sentences come in we
covered one on the bonus show two three
maybe it was more like four weeks ago
and we can kind of argue over okay eight
years 12 6 15 and then if for good
behavior and prison overcrowding they'll
probably serve half
whatever ultimately is the number of
days and weeks and months that these
individuals serve it has to be made very
clear
that uh this is what they did on january
6th was worse
than just showing up and trespassing at
a business right like on paper the
literal charges that might be there
isolated from the political reality and
the movement and the mob mentality that
that
was part of what was going on
might not be as bad as 10 12 years in
prison
but that the overall event that they
participated in and its relationship to
having a functioning democracy etc
makes it worse there's sort of an
enhancement component there that has to
be taken into consideration and i hope
that we see the book thrown at the trump
rioters from january 6th as much as
hopefully the book will continue to be
thrown at the accused here if they are
found guilty of course or if they strike
plea deals when it comes to the plot to
kidnap governor gretchen whitmer and
it's it's actually crazy that because of
all the different things that were going
on at this time and because of the
complete daily scandal of the trump
administration at the time that this was
going on this also this feels like it
was a relatively minor story and a long
time ago but this is this is crazy this
is crazy a concerted effort to kidnap a
governor
and uh so far one down and many more to
go um ty garbin will have to spend more
than six years in prison maybe only
three for good behavior right we'll have
to see about that but we'll continue to
follow other sentences that come forward
we have a a good uh
court decision
to tell you today regarding the pandemic
and guidelines there is a dallas county
judge that has ruled against texas
governor greg abbott's move to ban mass
mandates in the state now
you if if you're watching from another
country for example and you're in a
country that makes a little more sense
than the united states thanks to the
republican party
you might assume
if governors are going to get involved
with mass mandates you would think
governors would say hey i'm not leaving
it up to the to the local level
all schools must um have a mask
requirement in place for the time being
for the upcoming fall semester um in
order to prevent the spread but you
would be wrong
the involvement of governors in mass
mandates particularly in red states
places like florida
florida's a very 50 50 state but with
ron desantis the republican governor
texas with greg abbott the involvement
of governors has been to ban
mask mandates or at least to try to
to ban vaccine requirements or at least
to try to and a dallas county judge says
no
you can't enforce it you can't do it you
can't ban mass mandates if that is what
municipalities or schools or whoever
wants to do judge tanya parker sided
with dallas county judge clay jenkins on
wednesday issuing a temporary injunction
against abbott's ban on mask mandates
the move will allow jenkins mask order
in addition to similar policies in other
local school districts to remain in
place for the time being jenkins will
now have the ability to issue penalties
to individuals who don't comply with the
county's policy which requires that
masks are worn in businesses schools and
county-owned buildings
parker wrote in the ruling that jenkins
proved that dallas county residents
quote will suffer probable imminent and
irreparable injury through county judge
jenkins being precluded from exercising
his authority to mandate masks in public
so what what the decision is and
sometimes it's like
was the was something banned or was the
ban banned or did they ban bans on band
okay you get it
the decision here is
the governor can't ban
mask requirements as a as an umbrella
uh decision or or direction the
controversy in dallas began when
commissioner j.j koch filed a lawsuit
against jenkins earlier this month after
being removed from a courtroom for
refusing to wear a mask jenkins
responded by filing a lawsuit against
abbott over an executive order he signed
that banned mass mandates uh if you
think this is the end of the road for
this it is not the temporary injunction
will likely be appealed to the fifth
court of appeals in dallas and then to
the supreme texas supreme court before a
final ruling is made abbott's office
said in a statement it believes
in the state attorney general's ability
to defend the executive order
imagine for a moment
not only the money that could be saved
but potentially the number of infections
that could be prevented
hospitalizations that could be prevented
and some number of deaths that could be
prevented
if instead of focusing
on banning public safety guidelines
instead the texas governor and his
office focused on encouraging
vaccination
encouraging safety protocol and working
to actually get beyond the pandemic
rather than these pathetic shows about
liberty and freedom and whatever else
but unfortunately like we see it as a
not only a waste of time but as
something that's bad for public health
the republican party
particularly in these red states is
about obstructing
um
bringing down anything and anyone who is
trying to make a positive impact under
the guise of so-called freedom and
liberty
and unless they start losing
they are probably going to continue
doing this for a long time because as
i've said before they've completely
abandoned policy uh and if you think
this is the only thing that greg abbott
is doing no yesterday actually executive
order ga39
this is a vaccine mandate ban
and the idea here is to prohibit vaccine
mandates and vaccine passports subject
to legislative action so while this is
getting struck down he's trying to
prevent vaccine mandates and vaccine
requirements and they claim to be about
liberty freedom and not regulating
business but yet they're going out of
their way to say we need the government
to ban a private business from making
whatever decision is right for them
normally these are the people who say if
something is the right decision for a
business or even if it's the wrong
decision but they think it's the right
decision they should be free to make
that mistake or to take the correct
action uh except when they want to say
hey you know what it would be really bad
for our business for unvaccinated people
to come in and start spreading the virus
so we're going to require vax proof of
vaccination oh no no
now we need the full power of government
to regulate these people not surprising
they've been hypocrites for a very very
long time
uh and hopefully i mean we're we're sort
of in a race here not only against the
virus but we're in a legis in a um uh
a judicial race of sorts where we're
constantly needing courts to weigh in
and to prevent destructive actions often
self-destructive actions and if you want
to take a look at where texas may be
heading just look at the coveted
hellscape that is florida uh look at
mississippi look at alabama texas
benefits from the fact that their health
care infrastructure
is better than mississippi and alabama
mississippi and alabama are absolutely
the worst and
look at what's happening in their icus
but it is hitting texas as well as i
covered yesterday
three independent emergency rooms in
texas have had to close
because the uh organization that runs
them
needed to take all of their staff and
bring them to other facilities
overloaded with kovid so as we've said
before if you get into a car accident in
texas you're vaccinated
you have a health issue that it's not
even coveted related you get into a car
accident there are now three ers which
simply will not be available because all
of the staff needed to be brought
elsewhere to deal with covid
overwhelmingly in hospitalized
unvaccinated patients and this is going
to continue we'll take a quick break
after the break i do want to talk about
uh a bunch of you sent me these clips
from an anti-vaccine rally in new york
city
it's scary it's scary uh you know it's
entertaining and it's cartoonish but
it's also really real really scary we'll
take a look at those videos right after
this short break
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right so
a ton of you sent me news articles and
clips and audio of this crazy
anti-vaccine rally that took place in
new york city um i don't know i mean
listen i i understand that i think in
some sense it's surprising to some
people that this is going on in new york
city because new york city is such an
overwhelming liberal place but you know
it only takes a few crazies and in
particular based on the interviews i saw
some of these people were coming from
other states anyway there was some wacky
woman from pennsylvania saying she's
protesting against vaccines in new york
because she believes soon the mandates
are going to come to pennsylvania or
whatever the case may be
i'm going to play some of these clips
and
i i want to make sure everybody
understands
these are funny like it's okay to see
these as funny
and also recognize that because of it
the very unfunny reality of the
continued covet spread and possible
inability to ever get to herd immunity
in any real sense
um
may come as a result of the fact that
these people exist uh here's one woman
ranting let's just look at these i think
she has a baby with her and it i can't
tell if it's a baby it is a baby okay it
looked maybe like it was a dog
um in a in a carrier no she has a baby
and she's here ranting about how
terrible vaccines are as we see
kids increasingly
in icus with covet you know i mean it's
like there's no language that can even
adequately express the absurdity of this
let's get into the first clip here and
you know maybe get the kids out of the
room these clips are disturbing i cannot
afford to let my girls grow up in a
world where the government is allowed to
force an experimental injection
[Applause]
a usa chant drowning out the insane
anti-vaxx rhetoric what a country folks
[Applause]
okay yeah so um so that's that
uh i don't even really know where this
next clip kind of fits in this is more
about the tone than the substance or
more about the flavor than the
material or something like that
um
they did the national anthem and this is
this is another just weird this is
really a cultural thing
where whether it's a blue state or a red
state they'll have an event for anything
it'll be a mike pillow rally it'll be an
anti-vaxx thing it'll be an anti-mask
protest out in a parking lot we covered
this out in the parking lot the
anti-mask protesters i think that both
the pledge of allegiance and the
national anthem so this is just watch
your ears watch your ears but this is
these are the sights and sounds of the
anti-vaxx rally
yeah and it keeps going really you know
you this is how you fight tyranny right
guys
[Applause]
i love you new york
[Music]
yeah
um
guys what do i even say about that right
i mean what um you know we have
i
let's just move on to the next clip okay
i don't even know that the next one
necessarily needs any introduction let's
listen just as shirley and i love a sign
in here is discrimination based on race
gender age sexual orientation religion
and ethnicity have led to misery
policies that discriminate against the
unvaccinated will do the same thing
thank you
yeah so as you can tell there the the
idea is to analogize
that discrimination by a business for
example on the basis of race is bad it's
also illegal or discrimination on the
basis of gender
or sexual orientation although
discriminating on the basis of sexual
orientation is legal in many states or
religion or ethnicity or whatever it's
the same as saying hey you got to be
vaccinated to come in here because you
present a public health risk
being black and going into a store
doesn't present a public health risk
being gay and going into a store doesn't
present a public health risk being
unvaccinated does and so the analogy is
of course
uh terrible and by the way
being vaccinated or unvaccinated is a
choice now in a sense religion is also a
choice and we've talked about this
before should religion even be protected
as a class and
on the basis of it being a choice you
could make the case that it really
shouldn't
on the other hand there's the argument
that well it's such a a part of such a
core part
of what the united states is based on
it's a base based on freedom
uh from religion as well as freedom of
religion and you know i think the the
i'm not going around saying remove
religion
but you can make the case that what
we're really trying to focus on here is
not discriminating on the basis of
immutable conditions things that are
just who you are
and choosing not to get vaccinated is
not an immutable characteristic and so
the analogy is completely wrong uh last
clip here this is sort of a medley this
was put together by the recount it's
really good um all of these clips are
actually from the recount twitter
account which has done a really good job
covering this stuff this is a medley of
the anti-vaxx rally in new york city
take a look at this this is not an
anti-vaxx rally to force an experimental
injection into their body they're not
vaccines they're poisoned a vaccine this
isn't a vaccine this is some kind of a
bio
pharma
injection
[Laughter]
well uh
it is an injection it was made by pharma
i guess the the the prefix bio applies
uh i think we're maybe
talking about a distinction without a
difference there that that's maybe my
favorite moment here's another guy this
is a sort of a keanu reeves type guy
saying something very very important
ramirez i am a socialist proudly
you don't get many of those in this
movement
yeah so people booing the socialism but
cheering for the anti-vaxx now that's
that that's actually a really
interesting thing to talk about
um
for
i think for eight years on this show for
a while we've covered other anti-vaxx
movements there's never been anything
like with the covet vaccine but for
example the measles anti-vax movement
we've covered
and i've explained and we've looked at
this phenomenon where
you see these
anti-measles-vax enclaves in really red
areas and in really blue areas and the
reason is that left-wing anti-vax and
right-wing anti-vax have kind of been
pulled together
for different reasons the right-wing
anti-vaxxers
don't want the government being involved
in public health campaigns and vaccine
requirements and vaccinations okay
the left-wing anti-vacs are skeptical of
big pharma because they're skeptical of
lots of types of corporations and they
end up together and that's super
interesting where these really are
strange bedfellows let's look at that
again this is an anti-vaxx socialist who
says i am i am here
uh and i am anti-vaxx and he actually
gets booed for at least initially my
name is garrett ramirez i am a socialist
proudly
you don't get many of those in this
movement
discrimination based on race
gender age policies that discriminate
against the unvaccinated will do the
same thing this is a trick to get us to
have digital ids and they don't know
science but they know marketing
now that's wrong it's sons of [ __ ]
it's like attorneys general it's not son
of a [ __ ] unless you have i guess
multiple moms i don't know anyway that's
a very technical analysis there um this
is delusional this is really dangerous
of course and um
politics makes very strange bedfellows
and all we can hope for is that the
public health campaigns and the vaccine
requirements that are being put in place
make it just much easier to go and get
vaccinated than to do anything else um
and i still maintain that if error we'll
talk by the way about delta airlines and
vaccinations on the bonus show today
i still think that one of the ways to
most quickly get more people interested
in vaccines is for airlines to require
them in order to fly maybe an issue we
will take take up again in the future
okay a few other updates here
south dakota
has seen cases quintuple quintuple
quintuple
after the sturgis
motorcycle rally
two weeks after the annual motorcycle
rally in sturgis south dakota reported
covet infections in the state have risen
nearly six-fold it's a very unsurprising
headline
south dakota counted more than 3 800 new
cases in two weeks including seven
deaths
up from only 644 cases in the previous
two weeks
that makes it the state with the largest
percent increase in covid in the past
two weeks the state's rate of covet
infections per capita in the last two
weeks in is in the bottom half of the
country but it's the sharp and sudden
increase in case counts that sets it
apart meade county home to sturgis has
counted 330 new cases in the last two
weeks this is a really low population
place so 330 cases is a lot up from the
20 reported in the two weeks before the
rally so look think about that number
the two weeks before the rally meade
county has 20 coveted cases
in the two weeks after the rally meade
county has
330 coveted cases that's according to
the johns hopkins university case count
the 1550 percent increase comes after
the motorcycle rally which usually draws
half a million people possibly had its
biggest year ever according to county
sheriff ron merwin
and as you can see we're putting up a
map on the screen and i'll describe the
map to you the map is of all 50 u.s
states and what you see is that there is
one dark red state that's data south
dakota
and that is where we have seen a 493
percent increase over two weeks some of
the other darker red states include
nearby north dakota up about 124 percent
west virginia
which is up uh i'm not exactly sure what
percent
um indiana is looking pretty red up
about 99
and the lightest color states california
and nevada
as well as missouri and louisiana so
that's what's going on there and it is a
completely unsurprising headline
there's also the question of whether
we're going to see similar numbers um in
alabama remember donald trump on
saturday holding a rally in coleman
alabama
and
alabama
the worst slash second to worse uh
health infrastructure
in the united states
education is also terrible in
mississippi and alabama
vaccination rates are very low in
mississippi and alabama and so we'll see
whether we're going to get more cases
there now i know some of you will be
saying hold on a second david sir
you always talk about how outdoors is
really not a big deal
and mostly that is correct as we've
talked about even before we had vaccines
only about one out of a thousand coveted
cases was being transmitted outdoors
but that one out of a thousand was
happening when people were doing
obviously stupid things that they
shouldn't be doing like massing together
by the thousands and so if you are going
to see case transmission outdoors it's
going to be in situations like the trump
rally in coleman alabama where nobody
was wearing masks people were masked
together for some people got there 12
hours 10 9 ten hours before the rally um
and we're gonna see we'll track the
numbers two weeks before and two week
after two weeks after trump's rally
in alabama but it is not looking good
and people doing
really dumb things and i don't expect it
to change anytime soon sadly we have a
voicemail number and that number is 219
to davidp
uh i got a very funny voicemail about
how was i even able to enjoy my vacation
given that i didn't have with me all of
the different products and services from
our sponsors take a listen to this i get
it's a joke but i like it anyway david
sir
how were you able to enjoy your vacation
without access to your chill sleep cube
sleep system helix mattress or nebby a
shower head i know
yeah i had i had to deal with
um actually the mattress at the place i
stayed was was really good but yeah i
had to deal with the total inability to
cool my mattress
with the chilly sleep product that uh we
have as an advertiser
um i didn't even have blue chew that's a
joke by the way guys but that is one of
our advertisers i didn't have my blue
blocks glass i didn't have anything on
the trip and somehow i still had a great
time okay very good we have a great
bonus show for you today first and
foremost i'm going to address head-on on
today's bonus show
why has the bonus show been a disaster
from the technical standpoint on monday
tuesday and wednesday the explanation is
a sort of simple one and i'm going to
even ask for help with it
delta airlines which never refers to the
delta variant as the delta variant they
always call it like the one six two one
seven or whatever the whatever the
number is they don't wanna call it the
delta variant because they're delta
airlines which is sort of funny delta
airlines is going to be charging
unvaccinated employees an additional 200
per month for health insurance why well
because they've made an actuarial
calculation and they've determined our
cost for unvaccinated individuals over
time is going to be higher
uh are people going to quit delta
airlines we'll talk about it on the
bonus show and then lastly we have an
update it is not going to be a
recommended third dose at the eight
month mark it's going to be a
recommended third dose at the six month
mark and of course this is leading
people to ask
am i going to need a booster every six
months
um and also raising questions about why
don't we have a booster that is tailored
to delta
rather than the same old shot from 2020
and we were going we're going to address
all of those different questions on
today's bonus show
get instant access i would love to have
you on the bonus show really
sign up at joinpakman.com it takes only
seconds you can use the coupon code
myhippa
myhipa of refrain from many anti-vaxx
republicans myhipa use the coupon code
myhipa to sign up at joinpakman.com you
will get a huge discount
and oh people i got a bunch of emails
saying david what interviews are
upcoming uh we have a bunch of really
good interviews upcoming tom hartman is
going to be joining me soon i also am
excited many people recommending vincent
racconello i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly one of the hosts of the this
week in virology
uh podcast he is a virology professor at
columbia university brilliant guy from
the standpoint of virus
he will be joining me
and we've got a bunch of other great
guests upcoming so i'll talk about that
more early next week but for today grab
that membership i will see you on
today's bonus show or sadly otherwise
we'll have to wait until tomorrow to be
together again
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com slash david pakman